now just so I can level set and my
expectations of the audience here who
here has done some text mining in our
you can show a hand so a lot of you who
we use tidy text okay that's really
helpful thank you so in 2013 in 2013 I
had just finished my master's degree in
math and statistics I was working for a
Science Policy Research Institute and I
had a group of our scientists come to me
and say hey Tommy we need some stuff
clustered and I was like great I learned
clustering in grad school like bring it
on and then they were like here's your
data set and it was a bunch of documents
and I was like so I don't know if you
guys know this but I need numbers to
cluster and these are words little did I
know that my career was taking a sharp
left turn at that moment so skip forward
a few years a PhD student at Mason my
dissertation research is and topic
modeling so I guess I really just ran
with that ball but somewhere between the
two and I started I wrote a package
called text miner which is what I'm here
to talk to you about today so do you
guys remember Jim's talk yesterday about
Gmail and he had that one slide that was
in the TF package to try and download
his gene is Gmail records and then he
had to create some weird V corpus object
and it didn't print well and he wasn't
quite sure what he was doing and he got
really frustrated and abandoned it and
found another tool so back in 2013 that
was not an option that was available to
me so text miner really started as a
series of wrapper functions around the
TM package and then also the LDA package
that I had written both to well
obviously to make my job easier but
really to enforce I think a more our way
of doing things which is text mining is
actually just statistical modeling just
like the rest of what we do in our so
released the first version or the first
public version of text miner with little
fanfare almost four years ago and so
it's just sort of sat on cran and been
churning away but in the intervening
period something big sort of happened in
that ecosystem which is tidy text so
Julia solji and her co-authors have
created this package that is a unifying
framework for text mining and our it is
a much more our way of doing things so
that really compels the question today
right if they've built this framework
and it's got wide adoption and it's
awesome because it is why might you
still want to use text miner so one I
think my way of thinking about things is
still you know pretty good way so it's
it's at least worth talking about but
it's also sort of evolved into a pretty
darn good topic modeling workbench so my
dissertation research is in topic
modeling and sort of as I into this last
point as I develop something and go
through a proof of concept and I'm like
hey this works pretty good text miner
just becomes a landing pad for that and
so I'll throw it in and it's available
to to anyone who would care to use it so
this is what we're going to be talking
about today I don't want one slide too
far this is what we're going to be
talking about today for the sake of time
I'm just going to get in it so first
just a little bit of level setting and
making sure we're sort of all on the
same page of at least about how I think
about these things so one of two core
mathematical structures you need to do
text mining is something called a
document term matrix every row is a
document however you're going to define
that whether it's you know a book a
research paper a paragraph a sentence
and every column is some sort of
linguistic artifact usually a word or a
pair of words we'll call them you know
grams by grams and grams and then inside
your matrix is some sort of frequency
measure so if we're counting that would
be the number of times word J appeared
in document I
the second score mathematical structure
for text mining is something called a
term co-occurrence matrix so that's
relating terms to term so it's a square
matrix it's not necessarily symmetric
this could be a count you could be
displaying a count of the number of
times word I and word J Co occurred in
the same document together it could be a
count of the number of times word I and
J appeared within a fixed window of each
other so like within five words of each
other that's called the skip gram model
if you guys ever hear about that or it
could be something like the number of
times word J appeared within five words
afterward I or something like that and
so basically these two matrices are what
we're doing math and statistics on that
basically lends itself to any manner of
natural language processing applications
and so a basic pipeline for for doing
these sorts of analyses is you've got
your raw data that are your documents
you need to curate them and clean them
up and turn them into a matrix of data
that you're then going to feed to a
model or algorithm you're going to look
at the results of that model and decide
if you're happy with where you are and
you might iterate between one and three
several times until you get something
that you think stands up and then
hopefully if you have a good model I
don't have a report the results here but
you know that's assumed but hopefully if
you have a good model it generalizes to
some sort of population and so you would
then apply that model to new data from
that is drawn from that population and
if this sounds familiar to everyone it
should because this is also just how we
do statistical analyses and so again it
is just sort of like a soap box thing
for me because I really I am a
statistician not like an NLP guy that
this is just statistics it's what what I
have found is that many NLP packages
both in R and outside of our there's
sort of these little like cutoff
enclaves of their own weird data types
that have this their own weird workflow
and syntax and it doesn't need to be
that way because it you're not actually
doing anything that is you know
meaningfully different than what you're
do
for any other type of data that you
would analyze so my second my second
soapbox issue here so many models of
text so I'm going to pick on word Tyvek
for a little bit they get wrapped up as
sort of this this black box where they
don't really differentiate how you're
handling your data from the statistical
or mathematical method that you're using
and you know that's really misleading
because a lot of where the battles won
or lost a lot of the different meaning
and how you might interpret the results
of the exact same mathematical model
happens here right so you're making
these sort of very fundamental decisions
when you're going to set up this data
matrix and that is where things are won
or lost so in a few slides I'm going to
talk about well I'll just say it now so
topic models and text embeddings are
actually the same thing just you just
give a term co-occurrence matrix to one
and a document term matrix to the other
I don't think that's terribly obvious
from the way we we currently think or
talk about these but so I wanted
something that that sort of decoupled
data curation from modeling so that was
a little bit more obvious so moving on
to scalability concerns right so I I do
actually think that a reason that a lot
of these NLP packages are hard to use
isn't because the people who made them
are dumb or they don't care about you
it's just that until very recently they
were solving a scalability problem and
the usability problem was second
we've now only only just now reached a
point where we we can just assume that
things will scale and so now we can
focus on utility
so a quick equation have you guys ever
thought about how memory gets allocated
and are when you when you create an
object like how big is something where
does that come from so with a matrix
you're gonna have the number of rows
times the number of columns because each
entry in that matrix is just a number
and that has to be given a memory
address if we're doing integers then
that memory address is going to be eight
bytes and I think if it's float I want
to say it's like 46 43 something like
that but
let's just stick with integers so I've
got n rows times K columns times 8 bytes
that's how many bytes this thing should
take up in memory and I want to divide
by a billion if I want to see that it's
in gigabytes now for most statistical
analyses you have to have like a lot of
that for it to amount to something so
how big could these possibly get in text
mining so this is a what happened when I
tried to allocate 5 terabytes of memory
on my macbook air so a hundred thousand
documents times six million unique words
and that was after removing stop words
mind you times eight bytes divided by a
billion is just just shy of five
terabytes there so it's just another
couple examples here so these are more
more moderately sized corpora you know
ten thousand observations I mean that's
that's not a lot in in normal statistics
land but you can end up using half your
half your available memory on your
machine right there if you're using a
standard matrix so a big important thing
in a lot of text mining and natural
language processing applications is we
need some sort of sparse matrix to be
able to get memory savings so we can
actually work on these things without
needing like a supercomputer or a big
server I'm gonna come back to that in a
bit so briefly we're talking about the
philosophy here so when I created this
package I wanted to honor three basic
principles I wanted to use data types to
enforce maximum interoperability with a
nars ecosystem I didn't want an Enclave
I wanted something that could just
integrate with the rest of our even if
it had nothing to do with NLP I wanted
syntax that was idiomatic to R so if
you're coming to text mining and you're
pretty good at R I would like you to be
able to sort of like have some intuition
of what's going on and then of course
for reasons that we just discussed
things need to be scalable in terms of
object search and computation time and
so I'm going to give you an example of
each one of those that I've
in text miner so the first year deals
with both interoperability and
scalability so we need a sparse matrix
type so the TM package uses sparse
matrices from the slammd package I think
that stands for sparse lightweight
arrays in matrices and then text miner
and text to vac and I think maybe Quan
detta a few others use sparse matrices
from the matrix package and I think one
of these things is not like the other so
matrix actually ships with the cran
version of our it's really well embedded
in that ecosystem in fact we actually
saw it yesterday during Jarrod's talk
and when he was talking about sparse
matrices I saw there's a little DGC
matrix and so it works with with glim
net great nothing to do with with NLP
but you could just make a document turn
matrix hand it off the gloom net maybe
that'll do something for you just so you
guys don't think that I am confusing
quantity with quality here's the
popularity of various text mining
frameworks in our
maybe you guys will like what you see
and you can help me out with that
so idiomatic syntax what does that mean
I'm not even sure how to define it so
instead of defining it I'm just going to
show you some code here so up there at
the very top that's interoperability
again your documents are just a
character vector you can store your
documents with your metadata and a data
frame or a list or something I don't
care
R has lots of base classes that work
perfectly well for this I don't know
what a Vee corpus is I don't know why I
should have to know what it V corpus is
and I don't know why you guys should
have to know either character vectors
worked fine single function to create a
document term matrix is a similar create
TCM function that's there as well and
then you want to fit a topic model you
just hand your matrix off to it so in
three steps we've gone from raw
documents down to fitted topic model
I've created an s3 class for all the
topic models that text miner supports so
when you get new data and you want to
get a prediction under that model you
can just use a predict method and so I
don't I don't spell out the arguments
there but it's predict object comma new
data just like all of the rest of the
models that we have in our and then
finally speaking towards scalability I
wanted text miner to use all of your
cores by default although that's an
option you can change but because of the
the size and scale of language data you
know we really need parallelism but my
cell phone has multiple cores at this
point right so this shouldn't be
something that's relegated to somebody
with a background in high-performance
computing and so I wrote this this
wrapper function around stuff from the
parallel package to handle
parallelization whether you're using a
UNIX system or whether you're using
Windows and then Jarrod pointed out to
me the other day that do parallel has
actually done that since 2011 so maybe
maybe that's not quite so novel and
maybe we shouldn't have statisticians
writing
parallel algorithms so I'll look into
that but meanwhile that's that's that's
what's running in the back end and so
very quickly in the last five or so
minutes that I have so my focus has been
on on topic modeling and so that's
that's where a lot of the modeling
components of text miner have come in
and so as I said before this is sort of
my mental model for for topic models and
text embeddings they're all basically
matrix decomposition methods so with
latent semantic analysis you're using a
single value decomposition you're
factoring a matrix with latent Deer clay
allocation you're using some
probabilistic decomposition right but
basically all of these well and then
text embedding she's doing that with a
term co-occurrence matrix all of these
result in these smaller dimensional
matrices so rather than having to use
dozens of packages that represent them
all differently instead I've written
some wrappers that sort of enforce this
so I've got one matrix that is a
distribution of topics over whatever the
rows of my matrix were and then another
one that is a distribution of words over
those topics and so looking at the
output of this is the output of an Lda
object in text miner and just focusing
in on those top two I know it's kind of
small but we've got Phi and theta and so
every topic model that I have either
implemented or written a wrapper for you
get at least those so you can actually
compare directly like do I want to use
model a or model B and spend instead of
spending all of your time grappling with
the syntax and things like that that
said I am but one man so I've only
wrapped oh I've implemented Lda over the
summer that was a wrapper until very
recently and then wrapped correlated
topic models and then lsi I've got a few
more that I've experimented with but
hate to compare myself to Steve Jobs but
defaults really matter you know he talks
about a computers being the bicycle of
the mind right so I have these other
rappers that are sitting around and I
just I don't want to release them until
I know enough about the model to say
that if you were just dumb enough to
just be like here's my data give me
something that that something is going
to be like a reasonably good choice but
I would love help so if anyone else
wants to give me a shot give me a
shoutout I'd love to get more models in
there and then these are just a list of
a subset of topic modeling helper
functions that are that are available in
text miner so like I said it's turning
into a pretty darn good topic modeling
workbench
so this second-to-last little section
here as I said I'm getting a PhD I'm
focusing on topic modeling and so as
I've developed certain things and
decided I'm happy with them you know
text miner has become a landing platform
for them so anyone who wants to use them
and finds them useful text miner is a
great place anyone wants to use them and
tell me all the ways I got it wrong you
can open up an issue on github so the
first one is a couple years ago I
derived a a real r-squared for for topic
models it's not a pseudo r-squared it's
not something that just looks like
r-squared it is in fact the proportion
of variability in your data that has
been explained by your model I've got a
whole other talk for this but just the
punchline and in like a couple sentences
you can look at the normal r-squared
that we use in linear regression as a
ratio of sums of squared Euclidean
distances in one space so we can
generalize that to n space and this is a
picture of total sum of squares and
residual sum of the squares in two space
you can generalize it to end space and
then you can get an r-squared from a
topic model because it's basically
saying under the model how well does
this compare to the document term matrix
or term co-occurrence matrix that you
that you handed me
in 2013 I developed a metric called
probabilistic coherence coherence is a
measure of topic quality and I wasn't
satisfied with anything else that I'd
found there so I used a little bit of
probability probability theory developed
this metric I thought it was great I
actually wanted to write it up and do a
small paper and realized I had zero
baseline for objective comparison to say
it was better than any any other metric
out there and then I was like oh God
and that's what my dissertations on but
I'm not gonna get into that now I
recently found out that somebody else
had derive the exact same metric in 2011
and published it and it really just
didn't get circulated widely it took me
many years to even discover that it was
out there so that's that's one less
paper I have to write so you know great
but it I like it and I think it works
really well I'm actually not going to
get into this so much but needless to
say a lot of my research has indicated a
need for some more flexibility in an
implementation of Lda and so that's what
I wanted to do so the LDA implementation
the text miner has has a lot more
flexibility for setting priors although
it still has pretty good defaults I
think as well as a more traditionally
Bayesian statistics sort of handling of
this model alright so in the future I
want to do a bunch of things I think
that update method is really important
because anyone who's used a topic model
and then said this is great now I want
to add new data it realizes that when
you retrain it the thing that was topic
5 that you loved is not topic 5 anymore
and you don't know where it went that
that seems like a pretty big usability
issue so I want to tackle that text
miner is on cran and I have stickers
they look like that they're in the back
and I have a ton more so I'd be happy to
give lots of stickers to people and if
you want to get started thanks to my
friend BJ who's sitting back there he
pressured me into writing a whole bunch
of vignettes and so they're they're
available on the cran distribution thank
you
[Applause]